I'm James Wahutu. I'm a PhD candidate from the University of
Minnesota and I'm affiliated with
the University of Minnesota's Center for
Holocaust and Genocide Studies. This year
I'm interested in two research questions.
The first is on the use of images of
atrocities by news organizations.
Primarily, I'm interested in the efficacy
of this and then idea that we could
consume African death and pain while
sitting in the confines of our home. So what does that then mean for
African victims and why is it okay to do
this? But most importantly, who owns these
pictures of African pain and what does
that then mean for advocacy issues? The
next one that I'm also interested in
and should be starting to act on in the
spring, is the use of perpetrators as
sources when news is being written and
news is being collected. So, I'm interested
in the relationship between quoting a
perpetrator of a mass atrocity and the
risk of the intensification of violence.
In my prior work it turns out that
perpetrators are pretty media savvy and
they know that if a Western news
organization quotes them, it gives them
the kind of cultural capital that they
need that they then hope to change into
economic capital during negotiation
processes and hopefully score a seat in
the new regime and the new government
that should be coming up. It's important for us as Africans
to be able to tell our stories, but also
realize who is telling our stories,
because whoever is telling our story
owns that particular story. In my
undergrad career, I realized that I
kept quoting Western academics that
were writing about atrocities in
African countries, but not necessarily
talking to Africans. The challenge is in changing how we
raise awareness about mass atrocities
and thinking about
the unintended consequences of how
we've been doing it thus far.